à
non non non
alors bienvenue à la cité internationale
de paris
les réunionnais ils sont répartis dans
quatre maisons dont deux qui se trouvent
ici la maison des points en france la
maison du cambodge la résidence qu'elle
la loi vers le canal saint martin et la
résidence des milles alors que tu fais
des visites guidées ou tu étudiante
non ces étudiants paris première ville
étudiante de france
dans cette mégalopole une petite ville
dans la ville la cité universitaire
internationale de paris
en tout cas si sinon ouais alors la cia
huppé propose plusieurs services dont la
poste se trouve juste ici le pavillon
administratif est juste ici ce pavillon
là c'est le relais social ou par exemple
on peut rencontrer des psychologues et
parler un peu de des choses de la vie et
l'amour
oui voilà mauvais voici la cité par la
maison internationale
donc c'est le gros bâtiment principal
douze mille étudiants 40 maisons sans 27
nationalités 5800 logement rachel est
ici comme un poisson dans l'eau
franchement les magnifiques les
bâtiments ils sont anciens certains ont
été restaurés maison vraiment bien
essayé de garder larchitecture de par
avance
alors ici
c'est le restaurant universitaire de la
cité où on peut manger midi et soir à à
3 euros environ toulouse d'humoristes
comme angers sco se sent si bien qu'il
aime bien aujourd'hui ce corps policier
wayne revue télé en plus une des seules
russian dans la maison alors je suis
tout temps avec des lyonnais
au milieu des 34 hectares de forêt ces
maisons étudiantes ont été construites
sur un concept des valeurs
la cité u s est construite après la
première guerre mondiale
l'idée était vraiment de réunir l'élite
de chaque pays donc de personnes
étrangères qui m'ont vivent tous
ensemble dans la paix et la tolérance
et on apprend vraiment de la culture de
l'autre
donc j'ai vraiment beaucoup appris enfin
franchement ça permet de de faire une
croix en paix sur les préjugés qu'on a
sur les autres cultures
voilà pourquoi le département de la
réunion s'est associé à ce projet 85
logements sont réservés aux réunionnais
pour cela un dossier doit être rempli à
la réunion de ski et aide aux étudiants
aux départements la porte d'entrée
cnet boss c'est une porte unique
d'entrée donc qui permet donc de à
l'étudiant dont de demander une aide
pour ses études supérieures en formation
initiale
donc nous avons deux dispositifs qui
sont qui sont en vigueur
donc la beauce et partent mental et la
location de scolarité pour ceux qui
s'inscrivent dans les grandes écoles
au-delà de ça sur ce même dossier donc à
partir de cette même porte d'entrée
unique
on a là l'étudiant la possibilité de
faire une demande de logement la cité
internationale universitaire de paris à
la cu et les critères donc déjà est
inscrit dans la région de paris paris
créteil versailles
deuxièmement être de niveau bac +4 donc
et voire plus donc à partir de niveau
bac + 4 il ya une certaine tolérance en
fonction des dossiers des fois sur des
bac + 3 mais la règle générale c'est le
bac + 4
nous ne recevons chaque année environ
150 dossiers et donc les plus des
dossiers sont classés par ordre
croissant des revenus des parents
cette chance rachel en a conscience tout
comme tous les réunionnais rencontré ce
jour là
avant
c'est pas facile de trouver un logement
quand on est étudiant en ile de france
et ses bas ça va on vit en communauté on
apprend à connaître les uns les autres
différentes cultures etc
voilà
en fait ici la maison de provence de
france nous propose que des chambres
avec salle de bain donc nous avons les
cuisines en commun donc ça permet de
rencontrer d'autres personnes et c'est
comme ça que j'ai pu rencontrer des
réunionnais ici franchement comparez
donc moi je t'ai de nice et pour le coup
ça bouge plus alors c'est hyper d'un des
cuisines partager avec la tête a
rencontré des gens à partager et à
sortir
et franchement c'est une bonne ambiance
c'est vers chaleureux dans son studio la
réunion est partout pourtant son horizon
n'a pas de limites quand on les
réunionnais viennent ici ok c'est super
dur sans la famille sans les amis sans
les pets les copains et les copines et
il est carré il fait froid mais il faut
pas oublier qu'on est ici pour nos
études donc c'est vraiment répond
peut-être à venir et aussi le fait de
quitter l'île et venir en métropole
étudier ou même à l'étranger
ça permet de grandir et donc d'apprendre
un peu plus sur le monde et d'avoir une
autre vision du monde
ben je vais vous montrer un endroit en
fait je suis quand même assez active
dans la vie de la cité u
je participe à beaucoup d'événements
j'organise plein d'activités et dont le
jardin du monde qui a été entièrement
réalisées par des résidents de la cité
basse et aussi grâce à un petit peu ce
jardin fait j'ai pu rencontrer des
réunionnais de la maison du cambodge est
aussi un des personnes d'autres pays
comme des allemands des américains
dépensent fugué et donc voilà
et en fait c'est bien de travailler
aussi en groupe avec des personnes qui
ont différents points de vues
différentes nationalités et long que
parent on rencontre du monde
chaque année ces jeunes réunionnais
réussissent leur insertion
professionnelle
grâce à ce dispositif le plus important
est temps pour eux de saisir cette
opportunité